resources names books I'd like to offer  Larry Dossey deal SS EUI his book called  one mind and Gary Schwartz this book  called the afterlife experiments Gary  Schwartz University of Arizona for a  while Larry Dossey goes all over the  place both of these guys looked at a lot  of stuff if you just google evidence for  reincarnation and don't look at  something heavily biased there's a lot  of bias stuff you have tons of examples  of little kids remembering specific  details where they were born where they  died if they were murdered who killed  them what the murder weapon does was  this stuff was dug up so I really want  to tie this back into